i am indebted to my father for living
but to my teacher for living well
a tomb now suffices for him
for whom the world
was not enough
there is nothing impossible to him
who will try
i am not afraid of an army of lions led
by a sheep
i am afraid of an army of sheep
led by a lion
when we give someone our time
we actually give a portion of our life
that we will never take back
my treasure
lies in my friends
remember upon the conduct of each
depends the fate of all
glory crowns the deeds of those who
expose themselves to toils and dangers
each moment free from fear
makes a man immortal
as for a limit to one's labors
i for one
do not recognize any for a high-minded
man
except that the labors themselves
should lead to noble accomplishments
for my part
i think that to a man of spirit there is
no other aim and end
of his labors except the labors
themselves
there is nothing more slavish
than luxury
and nothing more regal than labor
fortune accompanies the brave
[Music]
often the lies that are believed
become the truth
there cannot be two sons in heaven
and two rulers on earth
much is expected from that
to whom much is given
the lot of kings
is to do good
and to hear bad
what medicine does not heal
iron heals
what iron does not heal
fire heals
what fire does not heal
should be considered
incurable
i would like to be distinguished
not by power
but by the knowledge
of what is
beautiful the only true friend
who will never betray
is silence
remember
fate depends on the ability to manage
everything
a donkey loaded with gold will open the
gates of any fortress
in the end
when it's over
all that matters is what you've done
with the right attitude
self-imposed limitations vanish
those who do not know the value of
loyalty
can never appreciate the cost
of betrayal
let us conduct ourselves so that all men
wish to be our friends
and all fear to be our enemies
death
is so terribly final
while life
is full of possibilities
sex and sleep alone
make me conscious that i am mortal
without knowledge
skill cannot be focused
without skill
strength cannot be brought to bear
and without strength
knowledge may not be applied
when someone betrays you
it's because it is a reflection of their
character not yours
true love
never has a happy ending
because there is no ending
to true love
you